Halle Berry the one thing I've learned
over the years about Halle is that she
is afraid of nothing you chugged I
remember you chugging whiskey and you
were just on Corden and you didn't while
you were on Corden he asked you a couple
questions who was the one actor who you
would never work again you said to
people they both famous one used to be
not so much in your or we went to jail
what SuperDuper famous how tall are we
talking what sort of not you talk
there's a lot of short dudes in
Hollywood most of them are do you want
to give me one more hint Mike you looked
at me for a long time like you're gonna
tell me and I was like wow
for a minute I thought oh I'm just
talking to my friend kids right I
realize I'm on TV I was this close you
guys but don't worry we got this
exclusive on Halley's most recent
confession do you remember how you
celebrated your Oscar win no I was in
here and she was on the set for Halley's
episode of hot ones which premieres
tomorrow on first we feast YouTube page
that's where Howie told me she's in
talks for John wick for she also
revealed the one person who isn't
impressed with all her fame
eleven-year-old daughter Nala right you
don't want to turn her I look like I'm
Halle Berry girl right she wouldn't even
care
she made John Travolta the other night
and she didn't know who he was in how
so excited I'm like you're meeting John
Travolta and we walked out she said mom
who's that guy I'm going home and we
watching Saturday Night Fever
right right right now in Greece right
now can we they want to see and then
afterward she was like
[Applause]
[Music]